[Music]
the rural community of paine is home to
a brutal statistic
the largest number of victims per capita
of chile's former military dictatorship
65 year old sonia valenzuela still lives
in what's called widow's lane she was 16
when soldiers raided the street and took
her father her four uncles and her
husband of only six months
from the winter i saw that they were
taking away a line of people with their
hands up like this
my uncle cried a lot he said sonja
they're going to kill me and so it was
yes
the majority of those who lived here in
1973 were poor illiterate farmers who'd
benefited from a land reform program
[Music]
until a military coup turned the clock
back
in all 70 men were taken from here and
disappeared leaving their families
penniless
we were destitute my grandmother was
left to care for 16 grandchildren they
asked for milk for bread
but the worst part she says was the
search for their bodies and for justice
justice was finally served this week to
38 of the 70 victims who are honored at
this memorial
after numerous appeals the supreme court
has ruled to imprison 11 soldiers and
policemen with sentences of up to 20
years
lost two brothers two uncles and her
father
she says she's waited nearly 50 years to
be able to sleep in peace
i think of my beloved mother who died in
december i can say that i completed my
mission for her she fought for so many
years for this
yet only 33 of the victims remains have
been found
24 of them were executed and thrown into
a ravine
lengthened
they only found my father's glasses and
a bit of clothing the rest of his
remains have been thrown into the sea or
into lake rapple in what the
dictatorship called operation removal
seventeen other victims were executed
closer to home
this is the hill where the soldiers
brought them shot them dead and then
left their bodies to decompose the
squadron was led by a lieutenant colonel
magana but he will never spend a single
day in prison he died a year ago
peacefully in his bed before he could be
sentenced
many of the victims families have also
died that's why sonia valenzuela still
feels sadness
justice that takes so long she says
still feels like injustice
lucia newman al jazeera by nature